outside ukraine's shattered embassy in
moscow police and a few mournful flowers
in solidarity
this woman though with placard saying
one people won fatherland is all for the
war
do you think it is okay for russia to
bomb kiev and karkev
that news is not shown on the state
channels but these two saw it on
instagram and they hate it
a lot of people think that it's really
terrible
all of us
aren't agree with this situation
russia's foreign minister met today with
representatives of the separatist
republics repeating vladimir putin's
extraordinary logic that by invading
ukraine he means to set its people free
he confirmed it again that we want
ukrainian people to be independent and
have a government representing their
diversity
have a freedom to not be under full
external control of those who encourage
neo-nazism the genocide of russians and
using ukraine as an instrument to
suppress russia
sky news asked the foreign ministry if
president putin was in his right mind
russia's defense secretary has said that
vladimir putin has gone full tonto
that is english slang for completely mad
it's surprising that such evaluations
given by
defense minister of the uk regarding
authorities of a different state
i think he could have
thought up of similar
adjectives
thinking of british prime minister if we
talk about personal
judgment
as evening falls police prepare for
another possible night of protests
because not everyone by a long way
supports what their government is doing
i feel myself being ashamed for being
russian we're all going to burn in hell
for that what we're doing
i hope ukraines will be
they will forgive us
day because now i know first time i feel
the shame that i'm a
citizen of russian federation
facebook now is being restricted and
we'll see which social media platforms
are squeezed next
feels a little like a rerun of the
protests against alexei navalny's
imprisonment all of which ended up with
thousands of people across the country
detained put in the back of police vans
as happened yesterday in more than 50
cities across russia people coming out
against the war and promptly being
arrested
but it's not stopping them in moscow the
crowds grew
and it's in petersburg too this anti-war
movement has some life in it yet
dana mcnay sky news moscow